okay for people joining this livestream
is something a little different for us
we are going to talk about suggestions
and priorities for often language these
are suggestions that have been coming
from war from language users and we've
been accumulating them in this issue
tracker here um and I thought we would
have the opportunity to talk about what
people's wish list in this holiday
period for bugs to be fixed new features
new functionality and so on so I think
we have a couple of hundred of these
that are listed here out of from well
tens of thousands that we've accumulated
over the years but I thought we'd go
through the ones that people have
brought up these yeah these are all
recent ones from the pre-release tester
so these are all you know very fresh
recent issue set of people are appointed
okay all right well I think we should
just dive in start at the top these
alphabetize by category cloud and
development deployment they're grouped
by by area and then their number by
number that the second ordering is by
number so the higher the higher the
number in that little blue blobby thing
that's you know the more recent so okay
all right so we choose to start on cloud
and deployment here um by the way I
should explain to people one very
strange thing about my computer setup
today is that I've been running some
long computation and I expected to be
finished by now and here I'll show the
the status monitor it's running across
40 cores on a bunch of my computers and
those little red dots are pieces of the
computation that aren't finished and
it's been going down every few minutes
another core finishes its part of the
computation and I have been I think it's
one of these things that's kind of a
precursor the AI rights movement I have
felt it it you know inappropriate to
kill this thing given how much
computation it's done so I'm hoping
that's not going to interfere with and
who do
this livestream shouldn't do and I'm
gonna be excited by finally finishes
which might happen in the next few
minutes um okay let's start off with the
very first thing here better messages
for lack of cloud credits boy okay
that's items like a bug so cuz if
somebody here from the cloud team who
can speak to they have mats kay here
okay so Matt shouldn't be on and Joel
yeah
can you see they stopped working I
couldn't see why I'm sure this work we
see with the messages that he got
because there should be some it's all
screeching for that as far as the
where's the screen screen under files
your mouse is very close to it this is
from Michael Salemi who might be on
there dissing well that's a bug to begin
with the fact that it says message text
not found
that's a hug to be sure yeah I was I
would think this might be within
document generator and more of a doctor
engineer everything in the cloud credits
things so looks like a pure bug that
should be tracked down and that the
document generator is okay so that's
using the notebook template system we
actually just have been updating that up
that template system to include
conditional templating for notebooks and
some other things like that so that's
Anthony in the UK is dealing with that
and that would be his bug I think I
don't think that has anything to do with
the cloud well maybe it has to do the
cloud credit system but it's flowing
through the notebook document generator
there's also a link to the that's really
all have we've got hundreds of these to
go through that one is just a bug and
should get fixed um
you
that's a good suggestion to put progress
and code could could you please adjust
your audio
um the that's a good suggestion to put
progress indicators in there we have
been doing a big project to standardize
our progress indicators and so I know
that we've we've talked with Fahim about
and I and I don't know what the what the
status of this is whether it's a green
light project or whatever but about the
possibility of having progress callbacks
inside the UM the blitzing on the name
of his the the the web stuff you know
the URL URL fetch and such yes URL read
yeah I mean we we have I mean in in
things like URLs submit you have
callback function I would say what can
we get back on noise out please
okay in any case um I mean that's where
the purpose for being able to use those
callback hooks to generate a download
status I think we should do this I mean
I you know I don't term and as I say we
are now standardizing our progress
reporting mechanism so I agree is a good
idea
where do we go back to here how do we
get back to the hmm make the right-hand
window in the cloud resizable I thought
it was let's take a look I pretty sure
that was but maybe I'm confused by
something yeah the quicklinks are not
but that's certainly on the cloud
wishlist for certain what do you mean
the quicklinks so if I go here you're
saying this is not resizable but I
thought that it was resizable when you
got into a notebook here um I tried out
the file manager or the documentation
instead of the quicklinks since the
quicklinks was just HTML they uh yeah
this this is resizable yeah the
documentation one is and the cloud file
manager definitely could be alright if
it's not then it's a bug hmm I'm here by
the way yeah yeah you know that that's
that's uh completely responsive so that
there won't be any design you did that's
just enabling it fine good thanks for
the suggestion
it seems now in terms of the quick links
I think that's less clear that that's
worthwhile because those links aren't
gonna do anything I mean they're not a
they're just a stack of of things there
yeah making it wider would just add
whitespace mm-hmm I mean maybe it's
worth doing that maybe it's worth
enabling that just so that people get
the sense that it's possible to resize
things I don't see that that would do
any harm well I think it's gonna do
anything interesting in that case yeah
and one thing you talked about in the
past is adding a little handle to the to
the separator line therefore the
resizable ones which has been you know
considered but then it's a little bit
more clutter just like a little
or something you can grab a witch on
here yeah not the quick clothes but yeah
for the documentation and the well when
you get to that when you get to the
region of that separator I don't see why
it shouldn't come up with something on a
hover effectively yeah that would make
sense that there is some kind of arrows
back and forth um Michael I live stream
is asking why not start with the support
or feature request tickets how about
make your file searchable from a search
bar um we are certainly aware of that
issue um the the issue is running our
text search system on these files I
think we are technically close to being
ready to do that you know the issue is
you have to take a notebook file and
essentially scrape it to get the content
that is meaningfully text searchable
we've got to be able to incrementally
run the indices for the text search
system and kick off those index updates
whenever files are updated there's a bit
of complicated plumbing there also the
text search system that we have is is
getting better and better I think for
12.1 it will be quite respectable um I
don't know what Matt can you speak to
the status of searching in files yeah
text search I definitely say if that is
far more respectable on 12-1 searching
files the biggest the biggest technical
hurdle hurdle there is definitely
keeping the your index as up-to-date as
possible right humming the question that
day as you edit your files you have to
make sure you know you get relevant
results in your search right I mean that
the fact is there's an update search
index which is quite efficient but I
don't know whether we understand whether
it can really be run sort of every
single time somebody saves a file I
think that may be prohibitive I don't
know yeah we definitely have to run a
whole bunch of you know performance
performance check to see what that would
do to the cloud right um
okay let's go back here oh come now what
is that okay how do i how do I get to
the whole thing do I save you all issues
here Legolas is zoom chatter out here I
posted in the rocket ship as well for
you we're not usually right click and
then I just opening new taps and then I
leave the one you know this is not our
system this issue tracker so not
responsible for this this thing um what
do I do here I say open a new tab yeah
that's one way of doing it's command
shift click will do it - okay that's
fine I'll date
local object I know could you please
adjust your microphone so we don't have
to hear this whooshing sound then um
okay set file date of a cloud object I
don't understand what this is
Oh to set the file date of a cloud
object just like you can set the file
date of a file it's an interesting idea
um this is basically time it's like
touch yes it's like your next touch um
listen there's people asking about 3d
Voronoi diagrams if we're going to talk
about that we need Charles and Roger
here
I'm here I'm good I mean we are where we
are wait wait wait wait we're still
talking about file day well that was a
precursor comet but we'll we'll get to
that in a moment let's talk about set
file date first um I I think this is a
perfectly reasonable feature request
it's a little complicated because you
know to some extent people want accurate
provenance of materials and to some
extent I mean like for example if you
set your file date back and that causes
the indexer to not decide that your file
is new what do you want to have happen
right in other words is the file in fact
new or do you want - is it like it like
I was just copying some files from the
1990s into the cloud and I want their
file dates in the cloud to be from the
1990s um and but on the other hand you
know I might want to know that that file
was modified ten minutes ago so to speak
um you know for restyling something or
or needing to re-index but Joel can you
comment on on being able to do set file
date
I mean stepfather for a local object
should be rather straightforward right
because that's this would be
straightforward okay seems like a good
idea
um okay we've got questions about 3d VAR
annoys um so let's just let's just set
context here we have Voronoi mesh and if
I do a Voronoi mesh of 2d a random real
um let's say 10 say 20 comma 2 I get a
lovely for an eye diagram
do the corresponding thing oh great is
this the version that was crashing all
the time um hmm do you want that crash
log John now we think it's fixed okay
that's probably an earlier version
because I'm still time running my
current term how do I relaunch another
copy of the same desktop not easily
because because apple says you don't
need to write all right well I'll run
the prototype though that that will he
be even more dangerous in terms of oh I
could run a let me go ahead and run this
prototype build um okay I was gonna do a
Voronoi mesh with I was going to attempt
to do the thing that people want to have
work and then we'll talk about what
doesn't doesn't work
okay so this isn't working
okay Roger what do we have to say about
this so we're well aware of it we
couldn't so you look at those cells that
come out there there are general convex
cells so in the 2d case they're polygons
in the 3d case there will be general
convex polyhedra now we got the width so
hmm
we didn't have a general polyhedra
object which we designed and added to
version 12 it didn't make it for the 12
1 release or we hope that we expect this
to be made make it for the 12 to release
so we now how do have random polyhedra
we just don't have random polyhedral
cells that can keep me connected enough
or annoying Nash's that correct they're
not random at all they're they're very I
know there's nothing wrong I want well I
understand that I'm saying funny shaped
polyhedra that yeah general yeah not
random general yeah right
um so we can do that now so that was a
barrier you know before that barriers
lifted but we still ran out of a
basically you know time resources for
them there was it alright so expected
for 12 to is what you're basically
saying yes okay next point on the live
stream is about split windows for a
document I agree that that will be
useful I don't know John maybe you can
comment on I mean we've we've talked
about this for years it's part of the
general project of making multi-pane
notebooks yeah it's a complicated thing
do you want to comment well I mean you
know we could we could work on split
panes without solving any of the other
problems and deliver it sooner of course
but yeah it's it's it's something we'd
like to do it's just a matter of
priorities and resources yes I have a
question I have a question why is it the
case that you can't open the same
notebook twice right
in a single session typically there's a
couple of special case exceptions but
typically I mean like the documentation
notebook you can open twice yes
so I mean and then there's a very
specific path for doing that that's
right I mean among other things you know
it can't be savable you can't have yeah
you can't have two separate copies that
both save to the same file that would be
very problematic I mean one of the
things that I've needed recently for
example working on functional repository
entries that have a lot of code in them
and a lot of documentation I want to be
able to look at the documentation at the
same time as I'm looking at the code but
I be reasonably happy to have a
read-only view for one of those I
wouldn't be as happy as to have a
readwrite view but I would be somewhat
happy to have a read-only view is that
something that's possible yeah
is there a UX we can imagine that
wouldn't be just irreducibly confusing
for that know if that's yeah that's my
concern is to is the confusion parts but
I mean split panes come with horizontal
splitting as well right I mean it
depends sometimes yes sometimes no the
you know it just depends on the
implementation right I mean there's also
complex UX to do with split pane I mean
I remember back from many many years ago
split pane editors that were super
confusing but I think those have gotten
you know it's gotten better in recent
times I mean like for example when when
they split views end up intersecting
what do you do
yeah and I you know I think most you
know first-class versions basically you
know they're live updating both panes
I'm right
well it's interesting to hear from
people how how enthusiastic people are
about split panes it's not something
that we're prioritizing super highly
right now but like to hear from people
about that um
okay let's see Wow um okay we've got
we're really jumping around here and
some of the things on the live stream
but let's address them Mohammed is
talking about date object and the need
for a half-yearly wow that's one that's
a good it's a great suggestion I I don't
think we necessarily have the people
here who would know about that but
that's a that's a granular date object
with a granular size of a quarter
you're asking for a granular size of a
half-year that's a completely sensible
suggestion and I don't see any reason we
shouldn't be able to implement that so
let's see who's going to pass that on
that would go to Nick I think I can pass
that on thank you um good suggestion
what's that okay somebody you know the
trouble with these handles that I can't
pronounce is that you're gonna you're
gonna force me to say something oh I see
I see ver an but I don't know whether
that's I have no idea how to parse out
those those letters so sorry if I'm
doing it wrong I see I'm gonna say um so
I see is asking would like to be able to
use open cloud notebook with a remote
Colonel imagine using the Wolfram cloud
notebook with a kernel on a Raspberry Pi
or supercomputer or whatever cloud
notebook with remote kernel we have
discussed that a node can you speak to
that at all
well I think you're gonna have to have
the notebook cast around your own
machine I don't think you can do it with
no having no but the issue is but no no
what we're talking about is this we're
talking about remote evaluate right
which is which is something that is
coming
I guess remote evaluate isn't available
here yet although I think I have a
version of remote evaluate right that um
and remote evaluate should be able to
use any of any machine to which you have
credentials to do SSH and on which you
have a wolfram engine running right
yes correct I interpret this is more
like like you know how it works with
Jupiter where you start a Koopa turn you
know a notebook server on your local
machine and then you connect out to
things you can connect to the other way
around is really hard to do securely I
mean I mean I mean even the you know
machines to which you have SSH
credentials I would not encourage in
environments where where we suggest
people upload their credentials to the
cloud it's more about like a like a like
a simple version of an EPC that you just
run on your gyro no I don't believe
that's correct I don't believe I don't
believe that's what's being asked for I
think what's being asked for is from the
cloud from the public cloud being able
to but maybe it may be but it could be
corrected but you know from the public
cloud being able to address a remote
machine and so what you're bringing up
is the issue of how do you get the
credentials for the remote machine
without passing them through the public
cloud in plain text so to speak right
yeah I mean you know I mean there's kind
of there's a trust issue there right I
mean it's and you know I mean even like
even if Wolfram is behaving totally in
good faith which of course we would but
but that doesn't mean that things don't
happen no I I don't know why isn't this
something like a three-legged OAuth
story isn't there a way of
authenticating I can't think through the
your point is that somehow our cloud
would have to ssh to the remote machine
in order to initiate the evaluation on
the remote machine that's your point or
we have to use another protocol which
we're likely now what about putting
presents
what about pub/sub with with MQTT or
something whether where the idea is that
what happens is that somebody has to
separately ssh to that machine set it up
a client a pub/sub client on that
machine
that can then essentially rendezvous
with a with a pub/sub client that our
cloud talks to maybe I think would work
so in other words you would not be able
to do it you'd not be able to initiate
the SSH connection from you know you
know what this reminds me of this
reminds me of some some Python program I
came across not so long ago I don't
remove it was but the idea was that that
it was like a it was like a secure file
copy from you know any system on the
Internet to any other system on the
Internet
and it basically involved you know you
would kind of submit a request for the
file copy and it would send you a token
you could take that token then to the
other system by you know you know by
whatever means and then be able to you
know access the file let's zoom out a
little bit why does one care so to speak
the question is yeah I I mean look using
a using remote kernels from a desktop is
absolutely we've been able to do that
for 30 years and you know in my example
that I'm running right now and look at
this it's almost done we're down to two
cores still running you know here I'm
from my particular desktop machine here
I'm I'm running a parallel computation
across 40 cores on what is it three or
four different with four different
machines here um and you know that
that's standard stuff from the desktop
but that's because there isn't an
authentication issue here because I've
got those those the authentication to
get to those machines is I don't exactly
know how it was done but it could be
stored by now in our system credential
mechanism all right let's move on so we
don't completely understand that one oh
wait a minute the idea we'll be able to
use machines and in which I'm logged in
with my wolf accounts so the Wolfram
cloud should be aware of the kernels
that you have
actioning okay so so this thing about
what you're asking for there in terms of
of having a drop down for what computers
you want to use well guess what on the
desktop where there isn't an
authentication issue we have exactly
that you can pick you literally you're
you're picking um from kernel
configuration options you are picking
which machines you want to use so that
absolutely works and has worked as a
matter of fact for for more than 31
years um it just is hard to do from the
cloud for reasons for these
authentication reasons um feature
request would like to be able to use my
local mathematical front-end with a
remote colonel on an ec2 box in AWS we
are well aware of this issue we are
actively working on it as a matter of
fact there is a a version the first
thing that is actually I will actually
probably use even today for something is
something that uses the AWS batch
mechanism to allow one to submit a batch
processing request that will
asynchronously be run and will well I
think in that particular case it was
throwing the results into s3 or
something and just returning some
information that the thing had finished
but the idea of being able to use to be
able to connect to kernels running in
AWS as zero whatever is yes it's
absolutely a thing we are actively
working on it I I think just from the
front-end I think you know like it
doesn't really like this already
possible I think John I mean like if
it's just a remote it's not conveniently
machine yeah I mean yeah what what
Stephens talking
would be you know a wrapper around it
that makes it a lot more convenient
where you're not having to do things
like juggle with IP addresses and that
sort of thing yeah but if you have to
yeah P address or the DNS name of the
you know easy to bugs and yes yes sage
connection I mean basically if you can
SSH to the Machine you know from your
local machine and you should be able to
set up a you know remote kernel from the
front end right
yeah with potential with potential
security issues but yeah hold on one
second guys I can maybe show you
something they just see I'm looking for
something here this isn't I can't I'm
I'm this isn't quite what I was looking
for let's see hold on one second
ah that's okay all right this is
actually a thing for running jobs and
this is not completely packaged yet but
getting there for running AWS jobs
remotely
I haven't yet used this I have to admit
this is a remote submit submitting to an
environment of a particular of a
particular file and being able to run
things getting back and see we get back
here and the elbe us batch jobs submit
object which you can then pull the
results back from cool
hey um nobody else thinks that's I mean
I think that's useful and I think that
is not quite the interactive use but
that's the you know that's the batch use
um and I I hate to involve people in my
issues but look at that we're down to
one remaining core that hasn't reported
its results yet so soon my computer is
going to be free again um
let's see would it be possible to enable
settings such as page size page
orientation header footer to be varied
within a notebook ha you know I have to
admit that our attention to printing and
pagination I you know we're always
wondering when the world is gonna get so
modern that you know printers will be
retired and it's never happening and
pagination I think is a thing that's
going to be there for for you know the
foreseeable future John do you want to
comment on those so my feeling is that
having said what you just said that if
you look at the world of issues inside
printing this I'm a bit surprised to see
this particular issue come up as you
know something of keen interest as
opposed to various other sorts of issues
I mean I think I could be wrong maybe
you know such features would be wildly
popular they seem nice to me but it
could be wrong well so I mean I don't
quite understand why you know one way to
handle this programmatically would be to
take the notebook you know given that
you want to prepare a notebook with a
specific you know page size change and
so on and you want to is to just do this
programmatically you just take the
notebook and write a piece of code that
basically searches for the relevant
sections breaks the notebook up perhaps
you use a notebook import to do that
perhaps use our upcoming form notebook
mechanism to prepare the notebook then
essentially programmatically do the
printing with those different settings
of options with notebook print I assume
that notebook print can take notebook
options in it I don't remember it's been
a long time since I've looked in
notebook prints well I bet it can um
let's see
[Music]
huh well that would be a thing that it
should be able to do I mean clearly you
can set up now that's unreasonable to do
it but otherwise you can't say and open
up books safe I think that books safe I
think there's something like that
or notebook open one of those too well
all of these notebook functions should
be able to take options that overwrite
the options temporarily overwrite the
options of a notebook I mean notebooks
save obviously gonna write them into the
save notebook but notebook print should
be able to do that as an overlay thing
in which case you should be able to do
this programmatically fairly easily yeah
um okay let's see Sandra is suggesting
tabs like a browser for notebooks yeah I
mean that that's a that's a whole the
making the notebook document something
more multifaceted is I mean there's also
the mini view thing that we've been
looking at I think that's something you
know for the next year or so is
something to look at it's not gonna
happen you know it's not gonna be a 12-2
feature or anything um okay Ethan is
saying how about smoother scrolling in
notebooks um other if somebody has again
background wind noise there um the UM
smoother scrolling in notebooks well
John I mean you can comment on that I
mean notebooks are complicated and you
know I certainly have these multi
hundred megabyte notebooks that I use
routinely and the main time when
scrolling is problematic is when there
are lots of dynamics in these notebooks
well I mean fundamentally it comes down
to the fact that much of the front-end
having you know being a child of the of
the 90s is is still single threaded and
you want to be able to
you know you want to be able to run
scrolling on one thread and do things
which might be required to draw on
screen on another and you know it
temporarily you know and instead
temporarily fill in with placeholders or
so what's the story of what is currently
being used in the iOS code base is that
multi-threaded the yes yes it is so I
mean that that and that's what we hope
eventually will merge with the with the
desktop couldn't yes yeah I mean that's
a complete rebuild of the whole system
that took many many years yeah um so so
if you look at the same thing on under
iOS and you look at notebook scrolling
on to iOS do you find that you have
smooth scrolling even for huge notebooks
I'm like wow so the scrolling is smooth
but iOS has a separate sort of challenge
where you know iOS is very memory
challenged and if you if you exceed your
memory you know it's it's not like
desktop where it's like well it's just
virtual memory you have not no no and if
you exceed your memory iOS will just
crash you out
and so you know we have to work very
hard to make sure that iOS doesn't crash
us out which means that we do things
like for example when you're scrolling
through the notebook when you get far
enough we'll start unloading and
deleting cells from memory that you
scroll past which if you scroll the
other direction we have to recreate them
so the scrolling is smooth but you might
be surprised to see like well I just
scrolled past this and now it's kind of
acting like it's loading it again so
that that's another sort of compromise
that needed to be made for that platform
but yeah okay next question that we have
on the live stream hatching coming for
twelve point one is there something to
demo for hatching Roger can you comment
on that yeah yeah why don't you just go
to well here we've got hatching all
right what do I say for hatching so if I
still don't its reference page and use
were just one of the examples I want to
do it myself then go out and do it
yourself
oh cool
wait a minute how do I get little much
finer of hatching you have to go to the
reference page which is not yet linked
ah
you
okay
so go use this wursten
surprised it may still be future I stir
now what's happening hatching is not
visible there there isn't a reference
page for hatching so changed name now
I'm trying to remember what the new name
is if you think it's still so handsome
lady no no that's for 3d I thought it
was called hatching and I don't know why
this wouldn't refer back to and this is
still a few tries page I mean let me
just guess I'm just going to completely
guess
I don't know why it's doing it that way
around let's try
so this is like when you get a
mysterious object and you're trying to
probe it to see what it might be yeah
well I'm very confused to what this is
doing here so yeah so you got a bit but
I mean seriously where is the
documentation or can we just ask Charles
now it isn't hatching I think you have
an old version I I put a snippet of code
on there and your chat there
I don't know L version unless unless
there's something this should be a
today's build but that's but that
caching that default hatching is way too
coarse way too close no it's not that's
not doing that that rather stupidly that
number is the orientation of the
hatching that's not what it should be
right and that's not how it was designed
I mean this hatching is ugly and useless
in my view um okay can we get Charles
please
yep try to get the function page again
it's called it's just called hatching
for me unless yes on the outdated
version it's maybe a misdirected I'll
till I have flashing an excised page I
can update documentation here why don't
I email it to you here
you
I can run
you
you
and that's not useful Rajesh what you
sent me is not useful they were going to
be called filling functions so it should
be hatch filling but I'm no confused of
that name change taking place so then
you need Charles here I mean it won't
let sir if you want to go on to explore
it more just we've already agreed on
this it just hasn't happened yet right
hello hi Charles what is the name of
hatching it seems to be hatching but
there isn't a reference page for it and
it was supposed to be filling right
hatch filling right
right I mean these are all the change
which have been happening the last
couple of weeks I'm still watching all
that okay all right tell us what the
argument structure is perhaps this the
same for the argument structure we are
still changing it all right so just tell
me how to make a fine scaled hatching
here in the current version okay fine
all right okay fair enough
but what will happen is the default will
be a nice fine hatching yes yes like the
line right but it'll be very close
together and then they'll be various
parameters that govern the orientation
of the hatching and whether you can have
multiple cross hatching and things like
that right yes the first version will
not have all do complex case but yes
fair enough good okay so the answer is
for Mohammed on our live stream it is
coming will it be supported in the
background
could somebody put themselves on mute
please who's making a noise thank you um
Leo the specific question being asked
will it work in the background of vertex
shape functions and graphs would hope so
Charles can you comment yes you should
just work house in your dog Aphrodite
yeah so they mean those you build the
shape functions and this is a directive
you can like any other directive like
hollow head yeah okay great so the
answer is there's a good good story
there and it will be in 12:1 so there is
people here Rob Ian Ben are all saying
they would use split panes that's very
interesting
okay um
Brian I think this is referring to the
remote evaluate is asking about
distributed trust systems like Kerberos
um yeah I mean as I said there is
certainly a protocol for doing this i I
don't think it is
um you know even running cover us for
example I don't know I don't know
there's anybody here who can comment on
this is anybody at Joel you might know
about this about key cloak and its
relationship to cover us and so on don't
know specifically if it supports that no
but that would be a mechanism but key
cloak is for private clouds I mean the
issue is when you authenticate can you
offender gate relative to your
enterprise LDAP system or relative to a
social network or something like this
and that's what key cloak is which is a
sort of middleware wrapper
authentication layer which we're
providing in enterprise private clouds
how much I guess we're also going to
provide in the public cloud is that
correct
Joel O'Malley I think I think there was
the idea is to use that says Matt can
comment on this yeah I haven't really
anything more to say than Joel does OK
ROCK wrong side of people here to
completely answer that question um ok
ian is saying he wants to report some
issues related to PDF um yeah i i'm sure
there are issues we would really like to
hear particular issues so and and just a
reminder most PDF issues probably
upwards of 95% of PDF fish
Jews are also printing issues PDF and
printing you know the vast majority of
what the front end does is identical for
both assuming he's talking about
creating PDF and not of course no
importing is a completely different
story okay
another unpronounceable either mr. actor
or mmm right sorry I don't know how to
say these names asking about machine
learning feature importance a way to
test what the model has understood for
example by measuring how performance
decreases when you permute some features
I do know that we're working on that I
don't know whether we have anybody from
the machine learning team here if we
want to get that question answered maybe
somebody can find a TN
okay
um okay we'll come back to that question
all right let's go back to the issue
tracker here um and oh gosh how do I get
to the bar openness use grouped here we
go um
okay we're going to there's another
question about machine learning on the
live stream we're going to get somebody
who can speak to those here because
these are questions I don't suddenly not
know the answer to okay this is about
none as a permissions category okay
that's interesting um
let's see
well that's a good idea to have
permissions to none for a particular
that's a perfectly sensible idea um
can you um Joel can you comment on that
yeah that's equivalent to an empty list
there I know so why don't we make it I
mean but it just doesn't work what does
it not look yeah it shouldn't work but
we didn't document it I'll check you may
not be called out specifically but it
may be you know implied by saying it's a
list of capabilities yeah we might want
to put a nun right at the bottom there
oh I don't know where that would go
possible classes actually no this is
where it goes down here yeah should go
right there okay good good suggestion
good catch okay next up core language
add a reverse rule symbol
avril on to a rule but no left rule or
reverse rule
well that's interesting
I mean I would say two-way rule which
took us a long time to decide to add
I've used that a bunch of times I said I
think it's a nice thing what is the
value of reverse rule would reverse rule
mean the same as rule or would it mean
something different
and his thoughts on the subject
I mean so something like this is that
all I don't even know how you would get
that I mean except as input so I'm a
little confused by this
um capable and replacement so graphics
that's a little weird if I might say so
we can ask follow-up and and find out
details yeah it's a little weird I mean
they you know that would be a different
syntax for I mean you know in in in the
world of arrows
you know we've got syntaxes like how do
I get this one um this it looks very
beautiful um things like that but I mean
this syntax would then be simply syntax
that would turn into B arrow a
so slightly confused by that one
Michael Solomon who reported this one is
on this only YouTube chat so you may you
know give us more detail in the second
later hey I've got a browser question
for somebody how do i I don't I open a
new window with just keyboard command
shift from the link command shift quick
well that goodbye at least done
something you know that's a tab
oh oh oh you weren't a window sorry I
don't know I always use tabs no problem
middle click middle click that's
fascinating okay I do seem to have a
mouse which has buttons on it so we'll
try that next time okay um don't we have
that now warning don't don't we have
that I mean we have a big project in
user Wow that's really weird that that
doesn't that actually is parsed as two
separate things yes yes yes we did talk
about this we have the context of code
assistants
yeah and I think we are going to put an
indicator at the end of that line to
indicate that there's a termination at
the end of that yeah I mean I mean the
real of course the real problem is that
some people use and presumably like the
legacy behavior you know so I mean we
you know we should maybe not be too
annoying about it I you know I think
that having a little indicator there
that that's the end of a line wouldn't
be the end of the world so to speak
because you know it may also be that
this is something that will simply be
part of code assistants as a suggestion
that it's the end of an input yeah at
the end of an input yes I just don't
know what the iconography should look
like you know it'll return character
there or something that was what I
suggested um
yeah it's a reasonable reasonable
thought okay alright let's try this
shift-click that generated a new tab um
asymmetry with part used on left and
right hand side of set
boy we man
have quite the right people here to look
at this this is an it I Jose type
question I think
I think this may be in the category at
how say if you want okay
let's go ahead and do that
I think this may be in the category of
there is no design that is convenient
for all purposes and I I think there may
be some glitches here in what has to be
designed okay so you're saying all gives
that which is right okay so let's just
try this case okay so you're saying
better if these were notebook fragments
this is really Rob
she'll assist you yeah
all right so list as this
okay so list a comma two gives that ok
now the issue is if we set that let's
say two XY
now what happened to list
what's
that yeah it's okay what's wrong that we
met
you
okay similar the following is also the
following is not documented for an
association
you
okay so this is an su all right so this
works just fine so now the question is
apparently it also works
all commerce'
okay so we've got
see a shin here
you
okay so a sock
of all comma C okay that's great
talk of all comer see
equals XY
you
that seems very dandy okay now
okay I see I see I see I see I see I see
so now the question is what happens if
you set that association instead of
being a list of values if you set it to
be a correctly conforming outer piece
here that's a quite subtle case okay so
- I wish I saw the return value there
okay so what did that just do
okay I admit that that doesn't seem like
it's right I admit that it probably
should do thee the thing that burrows
inside it's a good suggestion that
people understand what the issues were
yeah although I mean if it burrows
inside then of course that's what
happens if you actually wanted to well I
don't know maybe the presence of all I
I'm just worried about the fact that
that you know you might have wanted to
set something to a literal association
but maybe the presence of all well
though you could set it to it you know
you could say the same thing here and
that's not what we're choosing to do
yeah I think this is just an oversight
yeah but I don't think we have the right
people in this call to address it okay
we got a bunch of questions here about
machine learning and neural nets and
much of our team is probably oh I know
what the problem is I think the team
leader what time is it in Australia
right now it's probably four in the
morning in Australia I think team leader
happens to be in Australia right now and
many members of our team are in Europe
and that's reasonable time for them okay
so that explains why we can't reach the
the leader of that team um but we might
be able to reach one of the Europeans
is there anybody for an oceanic team who
joined this call
the only person I see added this
recently was Jose and I think that was
for the core language issues
okay well their questions here about our
more resources being put into neural
networks absolutely it's quite a large
team working on these things in fact I
was just meeting with them earlier today
um the yeah I think um we may have to
save machine learning questions for for
another episode here um a questions here
about feature importance about detailed
things about threading layers which I'm
afraid I can't answer offhand
um okay let's go on with these issues
here
let's see subset map should support
associations
you
yeah we are aware of these one and
working on it
it's a cool idea is it obvious what it
should do
let's see subset map so so what it's
gonna do is it's gonna take the the
named the things associated with
particular keys yeah nice idea good idea
we didn't think of it when we were
working on subset map originally um
subset map position that sounds bad
position specifications are inconsistent
yes we have discussed this one too there
are two issues here one is that the last
argument takes a list of indices instead
of a list of lists of illnesses so the
general position spec would be a list of
lists
they are simplified notation the first
one we decided to go with a list of
indices yes exactly so so users are
pointed pointing out that it's
inconsistent with with the result of
extract example but we did these decent
purpose just to be simpler yes I think
we need to have because the most common
use of subset map is a one level subset
map um Seth on livestream is putting out
outer should support associations to you
know I have this feeling that outer
needs to be generalized um in a
different way I mean the thing that
drives me crazy with outer is this weird
virag behavior which I'm not sure is
that useful um together with the well
maybe it is maybe it is useful but I
think outer if it's going to do that it
should be you know a list of things here
um rather than um rather than the
current ferox behavior where you saying
things like this
which I don't like at all um now self is
talking about outer with associations
and that does seem like a very
reasonable thing to do very reminiscent
to a bunch of the you know join a cross
type functionality how do you do we have
an associations expert here um and we
want
comment on this I mean it's it's isn't
there a way of doing this using
something like join across anybody know
anybody want to comment on that I think
it should work simply by nesting them I
think this is simpler than than it looks
because associations are one-dimensional
effectively so it should work like yeah
what you want to do is you want to say
outer F of the Association a goes to 1 B
goes to 2
okay and then X goes to 10 Y goes to 11
ok so what would you like this to do you
would like this to turn into the
Association a goes to the Association X
goes to F of 1 comma 10 right okay how
do you have a way to do that I don't
okay thanks good suggestion
all right um okay good this audio things
are so frustrating okay um options to
resolve options of F where F is the left
hand side and enclosing rule
what is that
what is this
in store so I think it's just shorthand
looks like right
like options open close bracket we'll
just act like options off the function
then you're in
Oh
think yeah as I underst
idea that said it's an interesting idea
I'm sure but it's an interesting idea
but I don't know I mean that would be in
an assignment and it would go in the
same family as options pattern which
does know what I mean I'm confused about
the semantics of this um we do something
similar for option value we do knows but
what does it do if it's op and flat are
some value up and close I okay we go
yeah
and the gives the value of name in
options matched by options pattern right
well this is a good suggestion
seems like a good idea
right I mean this is the same as option
value
you
should filter
yeah I agree there's a bit of messiness
here I think there's a good topic for us
to discuss in an Ald meeting can we get
that on the agenda please thing I'll
make sure that it goes into the LDO
agenda
improving the design of
you
you
okay
function instead holiday turtle argument
this is quite detailed very helpful
quite detailed um unfortunately the
relevant person Roman is not here um
yeah
I think we need to talk to him about
this this is this pretty detailed stuff
but there's an internal bug report in
the room when this comment is on the
pennies he's going to follow up on it
okay
you
a choice of stickiness yeah I mean my
only concern about this persistence
framework is well personally I haven't
used it as much as I'd hoped ooh I think
I'm just somebody I don't know it's but
obvious a psychological issue I don't
like assigning values to variables and I
don't like setting these you know I
never use set options I don't like [ __ ]
actually I'm not so bad about assigning
values to variables right but like set
options I don't like these global kinds
of things um so maybe I'm a
ah
so I'm just a little concerned that the
persistence framework hasn't had as much
shakedown as we might hope
but I I was you know worked extensively
on its design was pleased with it
alright data import option to not only
shoddy somebody can yeah unless we want
to go to a different section we really
have people here for that
I'll tell you what why don't we find
shadi and then we'll go to some other
sections
um data set we're working on it it's a
big project we're working on it
rescale should work on associations
you
not a foolish idea I'm why wouldn't it
let's see rescale
I see well that's probably just an
oversight isn't it
I think since you just look at the
values around rescale of the values of
the Association is that what it's saying
yeah yeah I think it's an oversight yeah
it's an oversight let's fix it
thanks for the suggestion hey this is
great guys this is really useful the UM
because something like this is quite
easy to fix and and um just an important
thing
go ahead I'll get internal work report
so just you know writing track but
there's a question of actually fixing it
um
well
should work on associations okay Same
Same Same Monsieur good good suggestion
okay in okay indicate default option
value and the new autocomplete drop-down
you
that's not a foolish idea we don't
always show the defaults we don't
because because typically the reason we
don't is because this autocomplete is
for things you want to type in yeah and
in fact I frankly considered suboptimal
when we do show the defaults in many
cases I mean I mean like here the
defaults I think is autumn well right
yeah right yeah and and that's just like
a waste of screen space however I think
it's an interesting point from a
documentation point of view if we put it
at the bottom right before these and we
said automatic paren default you know
with in grey paren default that might be
useful as a you know cuz like well if
you were about to set it to automatic
don't bother because that's the default
anyway actually let me make the
following point if we knew it if
somebody had done a set options and it
wasn't the default anymore what would we
do are you sure well I mean so that's a
good reason to not pretend it's the
default when it might in fact not be but
I think the suggestion that we could
potentially show the default as a piece
of documentation but it's got to adapt
if there's been a set options done
that's you know that that's important
um yeah interesting suggestion let's
that's for the user assistance Q um
shaadi is here okay let's just keep
going down these from it Auto completion
menu for the documentation search bar
heck yes yes yes yes yes yes we have
something in the prototype build right
now it's recently improved I'm not sure
if it will make it in 12 one or not but
it's we're getting there right but I saw
it here it's pretty weird I mean that
that that this this weird what the heck
is that we
thing why does it have that you know
sort of you know ripple effect John you
can see what I'm talking about right
yeah yeah I see what you're talking
about
it's just wrong what is it doing
probably because the developer who wrote
it - wrote it under Windows where that
doesn't happen and this is kind of a
platform sensitive the fact that you're
seeing ok I think there's also some
graphic design that needs to be fixed
for this but otherwise this is a good
thing this is exactly what we want um I
think that that should have an
appearance that is closer to the
appearance that we are used to given
that this is going to be a pure function
completion thing it should be similar to
the completion menu that you get for
typing in functions because this isn't
civil symbol completion a symbol
completion yes um you know because
something like that doesn't want a
complete although something like that
arguably does want a complete I think
it's a complicated issue whether whether
and by the way why not did not clear
that search for all pages containing
rescale it didn't clear that Oh what do
you mean didn't clear I understand
shouldn't it clear the thing that little
legend up there why I guess you're on
that page no nevermind forget that idea
but there's a question about non
uppercase things there um okay so anyway
this one is coming um okay so I think
we're now let's see we've got a couple
of different things going here um
Jonas you put yourself on mute because
we're hearing budget Beco noise um
sander is commenting on linear model fit
and so on being able to handle around
well who wants to take that roger who's
a fit and so on being able to handle
around that would be a wonderful thing
Roger can you comment on that
currently being looked at it clearly
should happen at some point but
the I think that's that that would be my
main statement it clearly should happen
I don't know what um you know I don't
think there's a fundamental difficulty I
think it's just a question of getting
that code base which has been a fairly
optimized code base to handle this
completely different kind of thing
I'm just thinking of whether it's you
know there's sort of a trivial way of
handling it and there's a more
fundamental way of handling it and
that's where this well I mean roads are
one of the things that I wonder about is
whether I wonder if the compiler could
be made to support around objects
because if it could do that then I
suspect a lot of those algorithms
there's a version of them that will be
compiled able that is pretty
straightforward these are not our most
sophisticated algorithms now I'm just
thinking of what's the meaning over
round okay
and what's the meaning of the output
when you have a round in the coefficient
I think I think we have a well-defined
calculus of what that means which is
based purely on you know there's
essentially a formula for regression and
you apply the formula and you apply it
with a round objects in it and you get
what you get
well I think there's a first some of the
results of feeds give separately a
result and it's error so the first thing
will be to add new properties
yes exactly embossed together so you
know when you do that
yes exactly so those computed results
they are effectively already you know
arounds but you know we didn't have a
round in version 6 when this was rolled
out
is this gonna work oh that worked that's
magnificent Wow this cuts it's probably
no
gonna scale because it probably treats
that as a symbolic thing and it happens
to work on the arithmetic that's not
gonna scale yes exactly
that's not gonna no but it does work
which is nice yeah for TOI TOI stuff
well I mean it's still useful that Roger
I mean I think a lot of experimental
data if you've managed to get data with
error bars that you know is giant so be
it
but I think there's an awful lot of
stuff that's comparatively small but
really useful to be able to do fits to
and I don't think we should be holding
up the you know the doing of small scale
fits for the sake of being able to do
huge ones because I don't think around
is going to crop up that often in really
huge ones this is what happens if we do
this I admit that's a lot slower but it
worked
now but that's not what I'm talking
about okay but in regardless I think
that the net effects for the user it
should work and the first thing that
should work is that we probably should
report them but that has to be when we
actually work on that function it's not
something you just you know we don't
work on we're highly leveraged company
so not everybody works you know we're
not working on all 6,000 functions at
the same time
right that's a little weird that those
errors are so big I guess that's just
the way it is yeah I guess I think it
was a random matrix on a conditional
maybe yeah um okay let's go back here
Steven I was able to get to get through
to Amir do you want him to join for the
machine learning questions good try okay
I think we maybe want to reserve this
for another time okay question from
tangled here OCR of math expressions
from papers actually that is something
that we are we will have some things to
say about soon I hope it'll probably
show up first in more from Alpha um and
yeah that's that's a thing okay let's go
back over here to questions about import
export option to not write metadata such
as the creation date into PDF seems like
a reasonable request what is the story
with that
so much twice PDF export doesn't yet
have an include meta information option
but import/export framework does not
issue any message currently for wrong
options that's why they think this
should just work but it's just silently
failing or or being ignore but include
matter information is something that for
a gift for example it yes we have that
what is its default value is it false by
default no it's true by default if
something exists in their image meta
information it gets exported by defy so
as you can turn it off
okay so the this is just a feature
request for immature include meta
information false being meaningful for
PDF oh I think so yes
seems like a reasonable suggestion is it
hard to do no once we have many other
PDF updates then the rosevilla once once
we work on this this should be very easy
[Music]
import support for genomic data files
boy this is gonna be yet another set of
people who aren't here sorry
there's two different things here I mean
we certainly have faster file import
again wrong people probably in this
meeting to be able to address this
completely is this already commented on
here no it isn't
how come this didn't get routed to John
Castle and people like that for comments
no it's got the internal bug report the
internal comments are in the internal
bug stated this ok communication for the
footage system is mostly between you
know QA technical support and the
external user and then giving updates ok
so this is also a request for out of
core access to genomic data I don't know
the status of that I mean we certainly
have we're doing a lot of work right now
on bio sequences and genomic data that
is a a good sensible thing to ask is
whether whether those out of core access
that is a good question from Michael and
so on I don't think we have the right
people in this meeting but can we pass
that on please
yeah sure
and this particular file type I am not
aware of so I can't comment on that I
don't think anybody here can talk about
that unfortunately
and ports should support video stream
guess what
you
this my two taps to the right
hello
you
what are we showing yeah I mean this is
just working right I mean if we go to UM
if we go to a random video improv one so
I see I see I see I see so where can we
go to a random video on the web how do
we get to a random video on the web
just use the one in example data video
of a random URL of a video does not work
why not we're working on it I see okay
so you have to have it be actually
resident on your machine yes now the
streaming case does not come but let's
see where's the example data one is that
video what is it what is the example
that's import of string example data
slash coming on this dot mp4 if you
unless you send that in a chat I'm not
gonna type it in um or alternatively is
it in the video
this is very goatee
you know somehow by the
product where you can say in fact I have
got to do this let us just take that
image
what happens if I do a copy that image
and I do this and then I say in which
identify did you try that already I do
that
be afraid of what this is going to
produce
a pronghorn
well I don't know what to know what the
best of times I've put pieces of code on
the chat you wanna I think that's what
they're asking for on the rock chair
okay all right so this is now a video
here do we have video frames and things
yet in this in this version which
version are you running today's
prototype should have it yes what do i
type video frames list of out 36 comma
fired
I don't suit us you're frameless single
are frame
frameless yep something like that yes oh
my gosh that is spectacular I hadn't
seen that work before that's really nice
it's really fast and I can really tell
what happened in this video now
I mean I admit that that that you know
it'll be better to use machine learning
to pick well I don't that particular one
isn't too harmful but um ah wow that's
really nice um
very cool so would would video ha
isn't that a useful function shorty that
I've been pushed used it a lot today
already that's a good sign um and just
just so I understand it I mean if I say
duration okay there's the earpiece if I
say duration of % 36 I'm gonna get oh
why didn't that work
that should work shoddy it's on the list
yeah how do i find that duration right
now it's important that example data
string comma duration that's horrifying
yeah duration obviously is gonna work
okay
okay Seth who I think lives in a part of
the world where he's more familiar with
these creatures says that pronghorn is a
very reasonable identification good um
okay let's see um so
what
you're saying okay Wilma your node is
saying what is this mooo thing and
always scared pasting videos and turn
until here it's gonna fail so that's the
suggestion to do to have the video work
from a URL I think I understand yes but
I mean that has to be the video has to
be downloaded to the local machine and
then cached right no we're gonna be able
to stream from the URL directly maybe
not for 12-1 but that's still on there
active for audio it was a two-step
process to you know the initial we
supported it but it effectively did the
thing of downloading the whole thing and
then starting then an iteration later we
got the full streaming where it didn't
have to download it actually starts
playing it becomes an active audio
object even when it before it has it all
but yeah that's exactly what we
discussed we're getting that first for
video and then we're doing the same for
all you right can I take you a look at
this and this URL is actually not even a
stream it's a playlist it's a plain text
thing so but it doesn't change the
suggestion but it's just FYI we don't
we're not having video frame are we
anymore no we removed it yesterday maybe
after the bills start this
is that going to work
why don't I go read you one you want
video your video time series of dominant
colors
and I don't know what this why this
didn't work it should work okay okay
okay let's go back over here
you
important format for videos
you
comments on that yes okay I mean we've
got some absurd number of video this is
that's not the that's the encoders not
the that right would that show up WebM
here or not those are those are format
types right those are format types did
you ask for encoders or decoders these
are the ones that are supported in
export if you ask for decoders
there should be a video format which is
the last
of the list there we go yep but so why's
WebM isn't WebM its own file format we
could register more of those but this is
just crazy how many of these things
there are yep
Electronic Arts Mad Cow video okay great
well glad was supporting it SVG import
oh that is an old chestnut I thought we
had a solution to this chestnut now
you
what happened to SVG well maybe briefly
somebody in your hands group had built
an SVG importer right which wasn't quite
operational wasn't wasn't than really in
good shape so it would import the main
issue is that SVG is a complicated
standard that has many weird things in
it that are not necessarily directly
representable in our graphics language I
don't know if anybody can speak to that
in more detail so at some point somebody
sent me a list of things that they
wanted to see added to our graphic
designers to support SVG import and I I
remember there were three items in the
list I don't remember what they were I'd
have to do some real digging to find it
again yeah I mean it's also possible
that as we've added things like hatching
and so on that we've actually you know
gotten what we need to do SVG important
well my recollection is that there was
some issue related to gradients and some
issue related to paths and III think
that may have a Glee may have been two
of the three issues that were raised me
we'll add gradient filling in 12 to so
it's part of kind of like hatching and
out of things now same story on the
functional repository Bob just put it on
a chat there's a link on the chat so
it's probably not perfect but it could
be doing like 60 or 70%
Wow cool for simple ones
see there's a question here of whether
we should build this in to the I mean
clearly we should point to this from the
relevant page but it would be you know
there's an argument that we that we
would be better building this in even
though it's not perfect I wonder if we
have a mechanism to do that well great
well the
read that back to this user and see if
it solves their particular SVG import
issues but I sha D what do you think
about that I mean even if this isn't
perfect it is a thing I don't think we
should start using function repository
functions directly in our system
actually this is a very weird thing here
this meant immediate format so that's
that's doing something very funky fine
but this is at least a solution as a
practical matter to that here's a
question um good I didn't know we had
that
a fast and safe way to parse numbers
you
you
you
that's an interesting point why is
interpreter slow for this case I thought
that was using a local interpreter again
we have the wrong team here but but I
think that's the correct solution it's
interpreter and it shouldn't be using
four numbers that should be using a
local code I don't know what's happening
there interpreter is faster if you give
it a list of numbers according to Carlo
but I don't care about that big question
is it should be local code and it
obviously is because that's much too
short for a cloud roundtrip so I don't
know why that's slow but it may be some
I mean the the the the commenting here
on I mean if I say table of ten or
something of these I mean I'm assuming
it's just going to scale
yes but if you give it a list of strings
like then then the interpreter is
actually supposedly faster okay but I
understand it but I don't understand why
it so you know if it is slow there I
don't understand why it's so slow yeah
so that's faster again let's factor of
two not more than three tighter of three
faster I think that's a question for
caller why it's the way that's slow um
but I think that's the right solution is
interpreter if you've got a raw string
like this I mean arguably this is such a
common operation interpreting numbers
that we might want a different way to do
it but I think there's a good solution
um
you
it's interesting Bob on our live stream
is commenting I think with respect to
the SVG stuff that that partial
implementation is better than no
implementation for example browsers have
partial on orientations of many things
yeah well yeah complicated issue I mean
you know I think a partial
implementation of SVG where it works but
doesn't import certain kinds of things
might be an acceptable thing it's just
that it's for what it does it's got to
do it robustly or it's kind of more
frustrating than not having it at all I
think yeah and you know people can
suggest that you know you're not being
entirely honest if you say you've got
SVG import and it only does a few
features well yeah welcome to yeah even
if you claim that it's not you know
fully supported but they're like it
doesn't work for any of mine you know so
yeah okay we gots a couple of machine
learning questions I don't know if I
mayor will be able to address them
feature importance and machine learning
a way to test
[Music]
which features are important how
performance changes when you permute
features I believe that we have a plan
right for 12 to 4 something which is
doing something more or less directly to
do with that is that correct to Mia I do
not know we can't hear you who told you
that
Amira's on the zoom but I don't see
himself yeah I mean came on zoom but I
thought you said you'd cover data at the
time so um because it's late he he again
locked off what do you want me to find
him no okay we'll do it another time I'm
sorry let's keep those questions and
Otto
we talked about that documentation
detail thumbnail is usually cut off what
is that about
you
about the magnifying glass
something
that's weird well that's okay so that's
the issue of a very low resolution
screen on the Oh low and notice notice
magnification has been set so that I
mean I haven't tried this but it seems
to suggest that the page isn't entirely
responsive to some combination of
magnification and you know it's not a
narrow window looks like a bug I'm
almost I'm almost led to UM show you
guys my
oh that's so exciting sorry I'm just I
just looking at my other screen and I
see that ah looks like my my computation
finished I mean I'm now I'm now I really
have to go look and see whether see what
actually computed the thing that I hoped
it would compute um
and
I don't think it returned
yet oh dear it's still so all the
parallel cause finished but it didn't
return the result yet okay let's not
kill it now did the map but not the
reduce something like that yes um uh
okay
oh no I know what it's doing it's
writing out a big data file um it's
probably writing out a file the last one
of these that it did which I did last
night took it like eight hours and it
wrote out a seven gigabyte file so um
yeah um um
it's not file hasn't shown
um I was going to show people just for
fun I I was looking at some notebooks
from like 1994 1995 um and it's just fun
to see because you can pull these
notebooks right up and if I can pull one
up there it is there's a notebook it
works just fine but look at the size of
that notebook that was my computer
screen size at that time or at least a
significant part of a computer screen
size at that time so you know I guess
there's progress in the world um
okay so this looks like just a bug we
should check into it
thanks for reporting it session submit
[Music]
could be improved by adding possible
issues section
[Music]
you
okay
session submitted the scheduled tasks
Oh
I was some
but flashing up of a notebook formatting
thing is a sign I think that my result
is about to arrive I'm sorry this
impinge Don this on this I really
thought it would be done long before I
was doing this live stream anyway um
okay
here what is going on here schedule
tasks justify it won't submit the
schedule task because session submit is
hold all is that right
so the assumed
there's nobody here couldn't address
this yeah I I think our vaguely remember
I'm trying to remember what the AC was
but you kind of have to give them to get
her for some reason
I bet the issue is that that's yeah look
session submit is obviously hold all
because otherwise it wouldn't submit
anything here so this is a mistake and
they're right that this should be
reported in should be in the
documentation the issue is
yeah I mean it probably doesn't say
anywhere that holds its you know what
this should say that that expression is
held and this should say if you want to
do this and we should give an example
where you say T equals scheduled tasks
and they say you know session submit of
evaluate of T
or you know apply it to a list of T or
something like this that makes sense
yeah it's a it's a documentation issue
as as there's been correctly reported
here all right let's move on and open
all button and the docs
yeah what is the story there
that's bad example because it doesn't
have a lot of subsidiary stuff but let's
try um okay so the issue is can you open
all of these don't we have an open all
on the web yeah oh you can do this with
keyboard shortcuts of course although
that's you know not necessary one right
the web has it yeah right next to
examples it says open all on a button
I'll give you a link if you wanna wait
at the same one bold yeah
thanks just asking yeah though we got it
right
well that seems desirable yeah I think
that's that that would be the thing yep
that's a that's something to look at I
agree
I have to say I'm really pleased with
these suggestions two really good
suggestions
no we'll just be useful for moderate
kind of smallish pages I if there's you
know some of these visualization
functions there options section alone
has like 30 pages maybe we could give an
indicator of how many is all yes that
might be nice open old paren 642 or
something yep I don't think that's
become necessary I mean why don't we do
that on the web can you give an example
of a function that has really a lot of
stuff let's plot I don't know what can
we say parametric plot 3d sure I wish
this sort of completed too
alright so there if I say open all I
just didn't do anything and it did
affect hi-c because it's huge yeah well
but it did work I didn't see it doesn't
seem useless to me Roger
no that looks surprisingly good actually
my it's very very attractive um
but these are all static images in the
in the product you have no idea what
what evaluations that's kind of fire off
you mean scrolling behavior I mean
nothing valuation think about like to
manipulate one order you know like I
mean like all sorts of things just
randomly start evaluating yeah okay
let's go back over here um
particular usage cases two particular
examples you know we try to do that we
just have not done it as much as we
could
right being able to go from here huge
page from here we do do that in some
cases we just don't do that nearly as
much as as we might Roger can you
comment on that well you're right I mean
so we've tried to do that particularly
you know so you know the notes don't
usually give usage cases but they might
give properties and other things and
then you want to link to an example so
that happens and it's just I mean I'm
sure a thousand some thousands of such
write it it's usually the more obscure
notes we try to make absolutely certain
as a link to an example other words it
might be incomprehensible right I it
would be desirable to get more links
like that it would be um
you
you
I don't think our documentation is
unfinished
well yeah our system even finishable
yeah you haven't noticed right then -
but but it's like we can never make it
good enough I mean it's just a question
of right but I think that's a look the
fact is when I write documentation and
so on I have to admit that I don't think
of those links and possibly the reason
we're not putting in those links more is
I don't know in the docq tools
documentation authoring system I don't
know how easy it is to put in one of
those links it is pretty easy it's
unknown if you're looking for an exam an
example there's one in Lisp lots no I'm
sure they exist well I mean if you
wanted to show people what they look
like it's four bullets up from the
bottom now yeah
pretty modest looking creature that's
what they look like yeah I know it's
what they look like I mean maybe they're
too small maybe nobody can even find
them even if we
I mean that's probably part of why you
know I mean the problem is because
they're rather rare it's kind of like
you don't even notice them we don't want
to over emphasize them because they're
so their comparatively sparse I think
there's something we should talk about
this in another documentation review
discussion what to do about these
because it's a it's a you know a self
self-defeating vicious circle you live
there so we did actually for version six
when we first rolled out examples we did
emphasize them and we did quite a lot I
don't think we've emphasized him as much
it's alright because we don't want to
emphasize them because on a page like
this it would look weird to emphasize it
you know it's just this one link we
don't want to over emphasize that
particular case but then there it's sort
of unattractive to put effort into you
know putting them in and it's unused
on't think to look for them um okay what
is it supposed to do if you're linked to
the example that's relevant for it yeah
yes I note the fact that you didn't know
that is a really bad sign um okay a
selador Thomas an example why isn't that
one I mean I thought that would be a
yeah it's kind of crazy that we're not
actually showing evolving a cellular
automaton from one of these things and
that would be a good thing to do Charlie
maybe somebody could add that it should
be very easy and you should just say um
I would imagine you would just say ah
Kalama gate
that thing does selling otorten evolved
from um i guess i have to do image data
right yeah that's probably the issue
that we'd say cellular automaton does
this work
you
and then a rape law very much well
something happened here looks promising
looks like it did the right thing anyway
just an example that okay um I'll see
Bob on our livestream is commenting the
parsing SVG is almost as complicated as
parsing natural natural language that's
encouraging
seth is asking about physics project
soon soon um bob is asking would like to
see more implementation of things like
animal properties um in Mathematica yeah
I mean one of the issues there we are
breaking up again probably nobody on
this on this live stream is some
concomitant ompletely different group of
people um but we're breaking up species
data which has been this giant thing
somebody's put themselves on mute please
um
the has been this giant blob of three
millions named species I think there are
probably 10 million total species that
are somewhat known in the world many of
them being you know beetles in the
Amazon jungle um but hmm or unnamed
single-cell organisms and things but but
we have I think about 3 million named
species and the problem has been that we
have not broken them up properly because
of issues about hierarchical entities
those issues are now largely solved and
so we're in a much better position to do
things like say you know list of mammals
and so on I don't know whether we can do
that but let's try if we say list of
marsupials if I can spell it correctly
um so that doesn't a thing that's not
encouraging oh well what is that
you
hmm that's a little weird okay
I don't fully understand that and I is
not really a good answer I mean see I
accept that this is this not a good
answer I mean it should be possible to
do an entity list of marsupials yeah
this is all goofed up um
oh you guys will be thrilled to know my
my my computation just finished it found
53 million objects of the kind I was
looking for ah whew um
now hopefully it's writing out a giant
file with all those 53 million objects
okay comment
so we're aware of the animals issue
and it is in the process of being fixed
and the reason it's been difficult as I
say is because of this notion of
hierarchy of entities that you know
something is an animal it's a mammal
mammal it's a marsupial etc and being
able to identify that as a an entity
type like like thing at all those
different levels why is this doing that
let me just well anyway um
okay Bob is saying an easier way to
refer to something like percent 23 I am
well aware of that thank you for
supporting that I have been pushing this
for several years
it's called percent modernization and
yes oh so our plan is to have a live
stream meeting about this but it hasn't
happened yet because of the 12:1 push
happen very shortly thereafter it's fine
we have some really good ideas about how
to deal with using autocomplete menus
more or less as you're suggesting to be
able to do things where we're basically
we have uu IDs now for cells and so we
have the possibility of having your %
thing actually burnt in so that it
refers to that same cell even when you
save the notebook and you you know
reopen it and so on so there's a variety
of evaluate things in a different order
with the different in our history etc
yeah but so um okay so let's say Brian
on our live stream is asking about
library link supporting passing arrays
of billions and strings you mean a mixed
array anybody address that yeah I don't
I don't think he means a mixed array I
think he means you know I mean we
support arrays of some types I think
he's looking for a raise or more types I
see is that something that we're doing
in library link or is that something
that's gonna happen through the compiler
the compiler has very basic support for
strings boolean I I don't know what's on
the roadmap for library like but I know
that we have been gradually expanding
the number of types right um but I'm
speaking more as a consumer of library
like who happens to know the people
working on it as opposed to someone
who's working on it so so what's the
bottom line and the bottom line here is
that the compiler is needs to be taught
about strings I'm I'm disappointed that
that's somewhat primitive still um well
it knows about strings it's a raise
strings I understand yes done but in the
good ireneaus about expression so you
can work with strings just have to do it
through data you know expression type
you guys will be filled or not to learn
that my parallel program did
successfully write out it 5 gigabyte
data file so that's good
makes my makes my minute or something um
okay external interfaces integrate ma
Tech as a system package so I mean we
are hoping to do more things with tech I
must admit that um you know we had some
issues with them
developer turnover and so on in that
area so we're a bit behind in that but
we had a very beautiful thing that can
anybody on this call comment on any of
that
yeah I have to admit that I keep losing
track of exactly where this project is
so well it's been an on Dre's group but
the you know unfortunately had a bit of
an inadequate you know there was a long
time it's going to be developed I wasn't
very convinced and it turned out that
the development that was being done
wasn't in fact very convincing sadly um
I know in the cloud we're all ready to
accept you know tech input as part of
notebook textual data it just hasn't all
been hooked up and I agree that it's a
really worthwhile thing looks like
somebody made a functional repository
latex preview that's on a chat not sure
if you saw that okay that's cute not
sure how that works
that runs through a third party API but
at this useful you know to have good
that's nice
really nice actually
just a bitmap presumably
yeah please me a preview yeah not
attached I think that friends too like a
web surface it's just wet surface to
does it
I said net that I'm not an expert on
tech but um I used to know this better
am i typing tear off or am i typing tech
here I don't know it's kind of like one
of those things were well I might have
lost track of time
is that tech or is that tear off that I
just typed there
what do I have to put a spices to back
backslash backslash to pass you know X
slash carrot is probably good
well somebody on this must know this I
don't think it's carrot that's right
well right now I'm failing here oh
what's that
maybe underscore yeah that's right I
think I was typing something from from
another decade before the time when I
used tech um
the superscript is just a carrot oh
shoot I am I am misremembering right
yeah okay well it's a little bit of a
ugly you know in terms of bitmap Barry
yeah looks like there's two different
API sets are supported so maybe it's
possible to get a better one but it's
nice is really nice you know a nice
clean functionality here um
call sage math from Mathematica I assume
if we can hook it up I assume it's not
very difficult to do that it's a
computer algebra system comparable to
Mathematica it's an interesting claim I
have no idea I mean they have a I think
yeah I once saw the chapel developed
that he didn't wasn't he didn't answer
what I asked him so I have no idea um
oops where did I go here
on page you can just click on I mean III
do think that supporting you know links
to all sorts of math II and other you
know there's nothing you know we have
now in our pull down we've got a few
other languages and I think we've got
more to come um and I think that the
idea of supporting you know input to all
sorts of what was the one I was thinking
of recently I mean some of these son
proof assistant oh yeah yeah shell
that's right putting the shell in here
putting proof assistant things in there
anything that doesn't have an incredibly
complicated set up is fair game to put
in that I mean the challenge is always
you know how do you get back results
that are actually useful I mean if I if
I type some random thing in here you
know the fact that that comes back as a
number is important um and I don't know
how to do because I don't know this some
does this work no whoops is that valid
syntax what and there's some range sent
is like the whole in Python sorry guys
um I'm not the
to him how do you try to do I don't know
what I'm trying to do trying to type in
something that's meaningful and that's
obviously not it either
I'm trying to make a range there's a
cold range as well oh look at that Wow
I guess that's what happens from the
fact that Mathematica existed for quite
a number of years before Python came out
I'm cool all right I wonder what other
functions of ours work there um
spot but but it will be useful to us to
know real examples of things whether
that's things like come magma or gap
those kinds of things which are
potentially callable I think those are
more interesting specialized packages
that do various things but the challenge
is going to be how do we get back the
data in a form that's actually useful
for further manipulation
right
you
what's actually on this on the on the
sage mapping isn't that now I thought
the project had largely died and then it
was reborn as some kind of commercial
cloud hosting thing so I have no idea
whether it's actually available in any
form that's useful I I would I would go
for some of the things like gap and
magma which have been around a long time
and which really have you know important
functionality that we have never
considered commercially viable for
support um and we've looked you know
we've been interested for a long time in
making links to those systems but again
it's it's a lot of work because it
requires defining you know how do you
represent all these kinds of groups
theoretic objects and so on in our
language and that is a huge amount of
work in its own right and just being
able to sort of ingest something as a
string or something like that is not
particularly useful okay what is this
sparse array and library link this looks
like a specific design issue and I don't
know enough to be able to comment on
this and what do you know about this I
really think we should be again wrong
group of people here but I really think
we should be emphasizing the the
compiler and the use of the compiler as
a way to pass complex data structures
rather than library link as such
oh my did I not tell I didn't do my
system install for uber
and Julia do we not have that now
there's a different thing this is this
is about system install as a function
which will just you know go and get Ruby
from the internet and install it for you
sort of semi automates the installation
of software for you I think that's what
this asking career yes but I mean we and
we are trying to do a Python we have
system install for Python on Windows
because Windows hasn't gone with Python
and so we make easy to just gather you
know - stop
looks like this specific item is just
asking for the same thing for Ruby and
Julia which is not hard to do it's a
good thing to do
I have no idea about these
I don't see why we shouldn't be able to
do something like that but it depends on
what it returns I mean if it's just
going to return a bitmap then I don't
know whether that's useful
you
these things we have in the function
repository and I think we're working on
making it better in you know an external
or internal evaluating start external
efficient right I mean this is the you
know it's obviously a nightmare of and
perhaps having a symbolic representation
of the tree of dependencies of Python
libraries would be a useful thing to do
it feels like you know yeah it it's it's
a kind of a weird thing for us to be
doing
it's like solve the problem of
yeah I put a link on the chance that we
have a whole bunch of things for a
Python might do let's do exactly this
installing a package on installing a
Python package you know all of those
things
good I mean the times I
tried to do this it's been kind of
nightmarish maybe these will improve it
yeah these are just wrappers around the
pythons package manager which is
collector enough the default thing there
um
make box four operator form looks dumb
evaluate what is that
what is this
wow this looks interesting external
evaluate can be called as an operator
yes it can
okay
and see look at this
you
okay cool
looks like
what
I don't understand this do you
understand us but but so what this seems
like it's I I think he's basically one
in a like a summary blob form of
external 9u8 of the return value when it
isn't so I see what he's wanting is I I
see I think I understand this and that's
an interesting idea I mean look if I
have an external function yeah I mean I
mean yeah I mean much like what resource
function you know resource function does
this yeah but look if I'd say function
tell me how to write a function here I
mean the name of the function is range
can I just use range here is that gonna
work yeah there we go so there's an
external function and if I do this and I
say that that our works oh look at that
it's your origin what do you know um the
so the suggestion
here would be a return type that is
essentially native that says you know
return type native and that would come
back as something which is a blob that
could be reused in that external system
again and that's a reasonable idea does
that make sense to people here right
because I mean just like here I could
feed this external function back
presumably in I mean
yeah I mean like for example in this
case I could take that string and I
could say external evaluate um you know
Python and then that string percent
sixty um what the heck did that - it's
still a string
oh I see it's a Python string Oh hum
language using container Python Python
string right right and so the the
thought would be to return it as a
native object that would display as this
Python string but when fed back in it
would know to take that directly in as a
native object and not take it in as a
string string object
I think it's a reasonable idea
listen to good idea actually um
still evaluate cell
you
the grey icons are not very recognizable
I've complained about this before I
don't understand why we insist on having
grey icons yeah integrating and I mean
this is this is a really interesting
thing and maybe maybe John can comment
on that well I have commented on it
before it's it's you know it's we're
talking about it but it's not
particularly easy to integrate into our
current system um I don't see why we
shouldn't know what it what is what is
she see this thing here with the crater
installed the visual visual code editor
the problem is that it's very hard to in
a notebook having a sort of an iframe in
effect it's not really you know that's
not really possible because you don't
get lots of other features that you need
so being able to have you know something
where you've got capabilities to have
like syntax colouring from other
languages in there is non-trivial we
know it's important but it's non-trivial
um yeah well this is this language that
may just be mocked up or something I
think that's just a second fell there
right that that I think that's just a
bitmap isn't it yeah all I can ask right
um but in terms of these icons you know
part of their identity is the color and
I find it confusing as well I'm not sure
why we exactly did that I think we
didn't I am we should revisit that
something for somebody could try and get
them on the agenda for the design UX
meeting
okay I can get that in the agenda yeah I
have no idea what it would take to to
like support MATLAB in here I don't know
what it takes to know whether there even
is an interface to it that you could
call I have no idea so if somebody knows
that's an interest there will be an
interesting thing I guess
support from multiline outputs
yes MATLAB has an interface called the
engine interface it's been there since
about 94 ok well so we could probably
call it so I mean if we can convert data
types which we should be able to then
that would be a reasonable thing
there's also a reasonable suggestion
it's just that I mean I think we in most
of these cases we have to it often
requires collaboration with the
organizations that supporting these
various systems so so long as we get
that we should be able to support it
I don't know what this is about
this is multi-line so that that's just
work to implement it you know like like
all these things kind of you know single
line is easiest and then returning
strings is easiest but then the deeper
you want to make the integration more
work it is remember the type of the last
external so yeah I thought we were doing
that fought for for input for typing
input oops I thought we were doing that
John that's I think our URIs you right
if I make another one here is it going
to remember that it's Julie or is it
going to no that's kind of silly I
thought we were going to do that John
can you comment on that
ecology Makassar unit and follow-up
there's a project management issue I'm
sure there's gonna be doing all right
this is just stickiness of did you hear
the question
John
Joan like if you're if you switched you
know yeah it's really not able to talk
so it's so it's just
Karla can add this to the list this is
something that we were supposed to do I
think it just got forgotten somewhere um
okay
Mohammed is asking can maple be
supporting next ourselves I don't see
any reason I mean I don't know because
it depends on that you know it depends
on its world not our world but I don't
see a fundamental reason why it
shouldn't be possible
um
I would think anything which has a
command-line interface where we can I
mean we are ultimately passing strings
to a command line version of a program
and so long as we can start that program
with start external session um then
there's no fundamental Ryo Kate look the
issues are starting the program being
able to and then when the thing gives a
result being able to um being able to
interpret that result I don't know what
what I actually have on the system here
whether I think you want something a
little bit more than that I mean I've
written these things that are pseudo
terminals and try to infer what the
heck's going on that's not very robust
I think you want something more than
that
yeah I understand it's much better if
there's a proper API interface and I
don't know where these systems have that
um
okay new katha is asking ran into an
issue some time ago exporting a 3d plot
as a PDF or EPS rasterizing it so
scaling didn't go so well
okay whatever the 3d plots could get
some kind of 2d vector description for
export oh I see what you're saying so
you're saying given a 3d plot if I make
a 3d plots and I turn that into a bunch
of 2d vectors gosh is there a way to do
that if you want it to look like what it
looks here then there are no good
options I mean you know you have to
remember ETS and PDFs you know PDF was
created in 90s EPS in the 80s you know
they don't support modern graphics they
really don't so well what do you mean by
that you mean the shading and things
like that exactly or transparency
well I remember transparency was an
issue from long long ago right but but
so what's your point I mean the the well
well well the point is that there are
two possibilities here
one is that you you get in EPS or PDF
it's not your high quality appearance
but it's gonna be raster the second is
that you get a compromised appearance
comment friendly look in version one
thirty-one years ago we were emitting
pure PostScript for these kinds of
things and we had very at the time
modernistic code that would do
resolution independent computation of
every little polygon yeah and and and
there weren't as many polygons well I
understand you know everything was
basically you know half triangles yeah
but let me make another point
those reports lat those were a constant
shades and main right did introduce a
variation shading but the the number one
problem was a different problem than you
guys are talking about the number one
problem was crashing your printer so in
other words we could send the data but
the printer might not I mean for a while
it was the case that you know like in
the early Macintosh days the printer had
a more powerful CPU than the computer
and so it was sort of okay but then that
stopped being the case and one would
routinely crash the printer I'm trying
to send this complex data to it so um I
mean you know if you tried to create a
high quality thing by emulating you know
every single variation you know
gradation as a 2d call then you're gonna
take you know what is here you know
described in I don't know a couple
hundred K or something like that you
know as bitmap and you're gonna turn it
into a you know 10 or 20 megabyte thing
for this simple case right I think we'll
start throwing in like this or something
but there isn't they're PDF there's a
later version that has a mesh
effectively a mesh there there was a 3d
extension at PDF and it never caught on
I know that they removed it they stopped
yeah but but there is this isn't still a
mesh in there in this I think the
question is really this if I want to
take this image a 2d mesh and spin it
into graphics just pure graphics where
that thing is a 2d polygon that's been
projected I mean it's similar to in geo
you know in our geo stuff you know
things get projected why can't we and I
thought we had this actually in version
one we had a mechanism for turning this
into ordinary graphics yeah
I don't think we want to go there it's
it's it's a very backward looking way
forward and it's gonna get worse not
easier I don't know may not we introduce
shadows and hundred things it's just
gonna continue I mean it's already the
case that we're doing such sophisticated
things just a handle transparency you
know I mean the sorting issues are off
the charts if we didn't have GPUs to
work with graphics would take forever to
render and we're doing the very
sophisticated things with the GPUs it's
not simple stuff all right we we need to
soon we should wrap up here but I I'm
really keen to just look at a few of
these these more algorithmic things here
make more of example data of geometry 3d
available as boundary mesh regions Roger
that's for you yes there's a ton of
stuff coming here I'll take this
particular point that's so that's a very
immediately actionable thing and it's a
good thing but there's there's so much
more coming for for geometry so one
thing is is web geometry search for
instance to get more examples with
probably we have that right and and what
it may or may not make it for 12-1 it's
it sort of on the cusp okay so the issue
is that taking the potted plant as a
region object mm-hmm yeah good idea
I mean it is objects he's just not a
solid they say you mean it's not
difference between when he says boundary
mesh region yeah you put a second
argument with John you get away John
object okay yeah I see okay so what you
is what that the many of them are then
then they're not solids okay
they are surfaces so to get to become a
boundary mesh region you need to become
solid and if your data is very poor full
of holes and other things it can't
become solid well right yeah talking of
which I am I I don't think Charles heard
this yet I was trying to take some of
the 3d geometry that I've just been
producing and we were trying to print it
and talking of things not being solved
this wasn't an issue of our system but
it's an issue of the printer let's say
the 3d printer failed in some fairly
spectacular ways um trying to print
things which were not adequately solid
not not an issue I mean that that our
region stuff worked correctly there it
was question of the fact that the
underlying object was not solid
detective two or more polyhedra are
intersecting or colliding
you
three polyhedra when we had that four
regions generally including polyhedra so
what is it that the what is it that
isn't clear here
so outputs a null list of no collisions
are pairs of colliding or intersecting
so in other words if you have a random
collection of polyhedra a random
collection of man and polyhedra the
question is which polyhedron intersect
why isn't that just region intersection
or region but what is there what is the
queue version region intersection but
the tests to do that is region disjoint
test why isn't the cue function well
because when they have parameters cue
functions are necessarily liars when you
need to get conditions back right but so
you're saying if I generate a bunch of
random polyhedra um how do I have to do
to get the number of spaces and I let's
say this can I give it the coordinates
of this starting point okay so I've got
a bunch of polyhedra there if I say
graphics 3d of that oh wow well they're
all intersecting so if I say region
disjoint of cannae what does it take I
see so if I say region disjoint apply
that to line 69 it should just say true
why did it do that why didn't that work
would it work with two of them this
doesn't seem right that it doesn't work
yeah well think about it in the support
of that new official public one of the
function we haven't yet completed you
know we don't yet fully support for you
at home
okay well that's the thing to do so uh
who is commenting on that um oh it's in
it's in here yes yeah well something to
do that just looks like a small missing
feature get all surface of vertex
normals for any discretized region
what is that could you say it again if
that all surface and vertex normals for
any discretized region
so in other words given a given a random
polyhedron yeah how would I find the
surface normals for that polyhedron well
that's a bad case no so what I mean it's
a bad case okay because Isis yeah okay
but here's let me describe some people
think that a polyhedron should be
faceted like a cuboid should look like
it is you know some edges and stuff in
which case you don't want normals on the
corners the step will round them off I
see okay so what you have Dennis of
course face normals to face normals
perfectly well defined for a poly drah
for other things when you use a
polyhedra to approximate something
continuous what you really want the sort
of corner normals and that's what's used
for it so I don't understand it this is
I mean some of the things like mesh
connectivity graph why aren't you saying
generate the normals for a thing you
know in there whatever tizen that but
whatever they asks so what what I was
gonna get to but but was that we
obviously have these functions but we
haven't provided a function to compute
or derive normals for you right so I'm
saying you you could say derive the
normals for the dimension two spaces
that is the faces here derive the
normals for the corners the dimension
zero pieces and so on and some of them
in certain cases will be undefined
am I missing something
yeah that's not actually a bad well it's
an interesting thing that we could do
for such a function it doesn't make
sense because you know in graphics
language because there we have vertex
normals only that's the only place we
have to store them we don't store right
face mutter right now we don't need to
right now
it seems like a useful thing to have no
it does it's not okay find many possible
um
you
polygon operation flinch
I thought we had all of that I thought
we had a call polygon simplify function
no
now simple polygons or is it a sin I
mean it's such a simplification no so
there are many connect what's the
question again
well the session is about about
simplifying polygons I thought we had we
don't we don't have that okay we do need
it and we need that for meshes and other
things to decompose from the image is a
decomposition yeah that's why I got
confused about it no I think I pointed
you've got something which is icy so
there's a sort of a union operation so
let's say that you get a the outline of
the US which is very detailed can I get
the lower resolution one a simpler one
that's usually what's meaning by
simplification with no I understand
that's a different thing I think the
issue here is you've got something like
this picture where you have all those
pieces as a jigsaw puzzle they all fit
perfectly together but yet you can't get
the outer triangle as a result from that
so that's what it is
oh that's in pricey provisional you know
should do that okay so currently a lot
of polygon operations including this
generate results were unnecessary
division of simple polygons occurs oh
right
in what sense
well the claim is that these functions
are generating unnecessarily complex
sort of fragmented polygons rather than
the the you know the thing which would
be represent the same region but with
fewer polygons all well I have to see an
example otherwise is a book especially
for art of polygons if you give me a
polygon I think this is in 97 check it
out Charles I think this is just take a
look at the specifics of what's here
okay so so they're multicam is a classic
he's not VGA you know you need traffic
right
polygons is the correct region but it's
not the desired region I think you have
to look at the specifics here yeah and
also in what class would he accept him
as simple simple has a meaning which
means it's not self crossing no I know
that but it may not be not that's not
what I think is being meant here ah all
right
for Annoying 3d we've already heard from
copper mesh region to arbitrary region
while retaining cells what is that yes
or no what if I should preserve this
table Joe right I don't understand this
is this something that's coming it's you
know it's a where do we do another sort
of clipping operation separately which
is a specialized intersection operation
well I put that into begin property
never returns yeah oh I see PSU okay I
get the issue
oh that's complicated right what do you
what do you carry over okay not sure um
comment on our live stream about the 3d
max I'm blender how they handle normals
with smoothing groups what is a
smoothing group that must be others
probably I'm guessing from my comment
was when you want it to represent
something smooth then you want corner
normals vertex normals yes oh I see I
see so that that's a the group of faces
which are involved in that it's an intro
ideal mom should check it out what
what's been done there find longest path
Charles very suggestion fine
sounds easy test if all edges of a graph
are distinguishable what does that even
mean
distinguishable edges oh I see that's
interesting issue right so in other
words the question is if you have a
multi edge so let's say I have a graph
that is something like um you know I'm
so used to doing these hyper graphs now
I type them in the wrong form um
something like that right but I could
tag those edges or I could have those
edges untagged yes then the question is
are those do those tags do those edges
have the same tag this seems like I
think this is for Charles to look at
this is this is a a it sounds there's a
potential of a lot of money to come in
later on on you know manipulation of tag
but you know we have to see what those
which one are quite useful in term of
workflow we introduced like in this case
we have each tag you can just look in
the a duplicate tag out of each tag he
will tell you if they're distinguishable
x-tags yeah of this under none
well this special kids love any tax so
here if you check also that is in
butakov
is enmity coffee I have no tagged in
right I think you should read through
this one in more detail I write we
should really wrap up soon this is some
that's a display form for fine shortest
path function what is the display of
shortest path function oh that's that's
ugly
yeah that should be done um it should be
done thanks for pointing that out
alright I think it's some oh I'd love to
go on with this this is really useful um
[Music]
let's see okay
doing part two on Monday so alright
somebody is asked to just to just type
in one input all right this is very
scary this is kind of like like this is
this is where my computer gets to blow
up um okay this is this is one of these
machine arithmetic is not commutative
issues I'm not going to be that
horrified by this but let's try this Z
equals PI what what is this well look at
what Z is you know after all those
settings
what is the precision of oh oh yeah it
has zero precision yeah
equal to anything I think the result is
correct I mean I think there's nothing
else you can do it's you know it's equal
well actually let's try this I'm curious
to know whether this is correct if I do
this equal to ten to the ten brilliant
it'll say false right so what it
effectively is it's representing any
number in the interval I don't know
that's minus ten to the six two plus ten
to the six
but it's any number all it knows is that
the number has you know those digits um
all right
let's wrap up okay well thanks very much
to everybody this was really useful for
us I hope it was interesting and helpful
for people on the livestream and
apparently I'm signed up to do it we're
signed up to do another one on Monday
and we will try and look ahead here at
the topics that he can come up and we'll
make sure that the relevant people are
actually available great okay oh well
lots of things here oh this will be this
will be interesting
okay thanks guys um
see y'all soon